one team has succeeded where all others
have failed one team sent Bayern back to
Munich with for lumps post-war kicked
off the seasons second half by breaking
the record holders for the first time
Vosburg and its owner VW seemed to have
made themselves at home in the
Bundesliga thanks to 50 year old coach
dieter hecking well half life what does
mr. hecking usually look forward to when
he goes to work in the morning as my
clothes mechanical department first I'm
happy to have time for breakfast with my
wife and youngest daughter this is not
easy with such an active family being
familia y all done and then I've got an
hour and a quarters drive i can use to
work out what to do with the day what to
watch for in training which players i
want to talk to one on one HP though was
he clawed some eyes that's what goes
through my head leave it and I might
listen to the radio little that's how I
prepare for my working day job except
for novel path why doesn't mr. hecking
fit in so well here doesn't see much me
every wannabe said what what I wish I my
live in the country outside votes book
has a lot of people commute to work at
the VW plant in the morning everyone you
talk to their says VW is a great
employer aleph obvious until Allah p
volkswagen tries to stay in touch with
its people who will need a fuels ind and
I've always had both feet on the ground
photogs I only ever wanted to work I've
never been interested in anything else
Robert I just want to do my job and I
think VW shares this philosophy Danya DS
a field of loss for the team has the
same philosophy and maybe that's why I
fit in here well it's a huge opportunity
that I spotted and went for and so far
it's working out well he's in Chaves
India because a don't you work your life
and you see it's keats good over nothing
there's wonderful home let's give our
imaginations free rein a bit a star
Spanish player joins world-class Bayern
the street ball player goes to
working-class Dortmund and the
down-to-earth hard worker 2 volts pork
is that why they brought you in that's
like wonderful Muncie to a war top does
doesn't get inside the ones who made
that decision know that best kind of a
bit essentially if it's true the choice
came down to ban Shuster and me for
coach that shows the club it made a
break of the coaching style eight had
before from place on franklin and Trina
reasons our antenna for feeling good no
matter I think Klaus olives was a
crucial factor oh the fela fiat vehicles
were so he also has to know who goes
together with him best many people have
been saying right from the start our
officer decking go together why is that
we don't know ourselves we spent four
hours talking it over in the kitchen so
what if all is it was thanks to you
afterwards I asked my wife would she
thought my children I thought it could
work out Klaus olives felt the same way
so maybe it's just really as I told it
may be my down-to-earth quality was my
trump card and on the head if you look
at the team's development over the past
two years since you've been with it what
words would you use to describe it event
nose to the time that's tough I'm not
that good at finding words what it soon
opposite you have so far it's why it's
good yeah but doesn't yeah so far I've
been good at it until I have to think
about how I describe these past two
years at the outset we described it as a
project we wanted to advance but it's
not just a project because too many
emotions and too many feelings are tied
up in it i think is the whole song
developing it has been fabulous phones
what seems it's only when we set
ourselves target dates we spent the
first half of the season fighting
against relegation and last year we made
fifth place you did not sonatas is old
now we're having our first international
season in a while we couldn't vanity
because I an open its fight his own and
I'm hoping will make the Champions
League hopefully over that so far we're
ahead of our time plans for dieting
that's why our development has been
fabulous I've done Lloyd Lee for always
in this obviously I'd become Kalos
Hollywood isn't true nice words you
chose that would be creating yes I'm
satisfied if that's his second place
behind Bayern taken for granted for
horse Berg and I know by no means at
least not yet it's only yeah it does
feel then Vic we want to get ahead
we want to settle into playing against
four or five teams behind by own for the
international qualification spots are
declared goal get it seen foot ones
we've already got the image of the team
most likely to give Bayern Munich
trouble dubai mention amidst my epidural
you can cause trouble cause trouble hunt
down yeah yummy a sundown we're up to it
in the active foci psych right now I
don't think we are because by instill
the measure of all things I look
disposal at English my buyer knows we're
here not because they lost four to one
but because they've been hoping we drop
some points these past weeks both to
support illegal we've missed elevate
points to go but the point spread hasn't
changed megawatt and our aim is to let x
and feel the pressure he's an OP of the
bunch so at least they'll feel a bit
uneasy always at dole about hot even so
I could imagine you wouldn't mind seeing
the top of the standings get more
exciting in the future what you god I
didn't gosh pizza it's a cool fun and
about and order dude it's fun it'll get
more exciting you can be sure that he
wouldn't see of it the Bundesliga will
never be permanently dominated by one
team three years ago everybody was
saying Dorfman would stand up to buy an
initial they crashed I'm lobster woods
but not even Bayern Munich is immune to
having an offseason now and then so no I
don't think the Bundesliga will be a
one-man show discipline other teams will
get a chance to move up closer and have
some better prospects fine barely move
be cut back alone every dog for instance
ox books been playing a fantastic season
this year with modest means solo FC
augsburg somebody needs Mia that's the
attraction of this lake side another
middle daughter fantastic song spiel and
this is LT of activities earlier